hey beautiful I just wanted to say that
last night was incredible you are the
most amazing thing that has ever graced
this planet I feel like last night at
the beginning of the rest of our lives
together I can't wait to see you again
my love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you bring this country I got to stop
and we'll put on the white one no no I'm
gonna put on the left one don't need to
let one come in okay I gotta make this
real quick you know we have inspired me
so abruptly like a shirt man how many
times we'll have to tell you you're late
every single day but I mean you're good
when you get there what really drives me
nuts you're always always a little the
vegetable term the buffet line it's
really nice though you bring brownies
and cookies I mean however like you're
in the bathroom for hours I mean
although you're coming out looking
beautiful people love you when you come
out but like I got to tell you this
thing that drives us all crazy
you're always on that Instagram thing
you'll like it you're searching I don't
know if you're doing the secretary they
hate you time really love Nevin in there
and I think I wanna come back
oh man we take a shower
[Music]
de meses a lot of sauce with a tea bag
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys me amanda cerny thank you so
much for watching my surnames guests and
liking and commenting i literally read
every single one of them so thank you
guys teen journey is growing and i love
it i want to involve you guys even more
so what I'm doing now is I'm taking
journeys get suggestion ideas that means
you just comment below any good ideas
that you have to me and if I decide to
choose your idea I will shout you out in
my next journey skate YouTube video so
keep the comments coming and who knows
it could be you love you guys and I'll
see you next week
thankful